حتى الناجون تطاردهم
الاسئله اين سيتلقى المصابون منهم
العلاج البنيه التحتيه للرعايه الصحيه
والعاملون في مجال الصحه في مرمى القصف
الاسرائيلي اما مشافي غزه بل تلك التي
سلمت حتى الان من القصف فدخلت حاله انهيار
فعلي تجد الطواقم الطبيه نفسها امام خيار
صعب بشان من يحظى بالاولويه في العلاج
بسبب انعدام الامدادات
وزاره الصحه في غزه تنبه هنا الى مخاطر
انقطاع الكهرباء وشح الوقود المستخدم في
مولدات تشغل الاجهزه الطبيه زيد على ذلك
نفاد الادويه والمستلزمات
الطبيه يخشى ان يفضي ذلك كله الى تدهور
الوضع الصحي لكثير من المرضى والجرحى في
مستشفيات عامه وتخصص في القطاع فقد تم فصل
عدد كبير من الاجهزه الحيويه لضمان
استمرار تقديم بعض الخدمات الطبيه في حدها
الادنى وبالحد الادنى تمضي حياه الغزيين
تحت القصف المكثف
والحصار تحذر منظمه الصحه العالميه من
كارثه انسانيه واسعه النطاق في القطاع
فسكان يعانون نقصا شديدا في الء والغذاء
والدواء
والوقود تتلاحق نداءات
الاستغاثه لكن مقرره الامم المتحده الخاصه
المعنيه بالحق في الصحه ترى الحل في وقف
لاطلاق النار يتيح وصول المساعدات
الانسانيه الى غزه تتكدس المساعدات على
الجانب الاخر من حدود القطاع مع مصر بينما
هنا يعاني الناس الامرين للحصول على كسره
خبز هذا فرن خبز يسافر بهم عبر الزمن لكنه
يطعمهم الى حين وهذا فرن زيت مش فرن
كهربا فرن اتر يعني زمان ولا 80 سنه 70
سنه الفران هذول لا عجب ان يصف المتحدث
باسم اليونسف الاوضاع في غزه بالحرجه
للغايه عندي ست مفار مش قادر اكلهم ولا
اشربهم فش عنا ولا غاز ولا ميه ارحمونا يا
عالم تلك ايضا احوال ما يدفعون قصرا الى
المغادره تدعو الصحه العالميه اسرائيل الى
الغاء اوامر اجلاء سكان شمال القطاع وتقول
الامم المتحده ان ذلك يصل الى مستوى النقل
القصري للمدنيين وانتهاك للقانون الدولي
باي حق يخير ابناء غزه بين الموت
والرحيل ما تزال الدعوات تتعالى مطالبه
لمجتمع الدولي بالتدخل الفوري لوقف العقاب
الجماعي او على الاقل لفتح ممرات
انسانيه تاخر ذلك يعني زهق مزيد من ارواح
المدنيين نتيجه القصف العنيف والمكثف على
قطاع غزه تنبه منظمه اليونسف الى ان مئات
الجثث لا تزال تحت الانقاض وانه يتعين
انتشالها حتى لا تتحول الى ازمه صحيه
ذاتها الازمه تشير اليها اوكسفام وهي تبدي
الخشيه من تحول القطاع الى ارض خصبه
للامراض
والاوبئه هي واحده من ازمات تشكل مشهدا
انسانيا في غزه لا شيء انسانيا فيه سو
اسمه